well it's my first fourth as an american
and i couldn't be more proud
as you know if you're a regular viewer a
couple of months ago i became a u.s
citizen and i'm so happy
to be celebrating this very special day
with all of you my fellow americans
and while that's still a new thing for
me to be saying the reality is i felt
like this was my home for years
ever since we crossed the pond and moved
to california nearly a decade ago
the truth is the more i've learned about
america the more i love america
the more i've learned about our history
our culture and our traditions the more
i appreciate
that there is no better place on earth
and no better model
for the rest of the world not perfect
but working towards that more perfect
union every day
that's why i was so offended by what
jen sarki said at the podium in the
white house a few days ago
on behalf of the president of the united
states
in response to that athlete
disrespecting our flag and our anthem
sarki said
it's okay to disrespect the flag because
america hasn't always lived up to our
highest ideals
what a ludicrous shallow and divisive
thing to say of course we haven't always
lived up to our highest ideals those
ideals
are pretty high you might even say
unattainable
the whole point is that they serve as a
unifying
aspiration for the whole nation and
let's get specific because we know what
gensake was really talking about
it was race and of course it's true that
still today
there is far too much racial injustice
in this country
but even as we acknowledge that can
anyone name
a single country on earth that offers
more opportunity to those from any race
and any background
than america where do these people like
jen
saki so quick to denigrate america what
do they think is a better place to live
if you're black or latino or asian or
anyone who isn't an evil racist white
person
why do these athletes these activists
these self-hating talking heads on tv
who run around
casually smearing the one country their
own country
that welcomes more immigrants more
refugees and gives them more chances
than any other place in the world why do
they think those millions of people yes
still the tired the poor the huddled
masses yearning to breathe free
why do they want to come here to america
if this country is so racist
so irredeemably structurally racist
my parents grew up under communism in
hungary
my stepfather also hungarian literally
escaped across the border
during the 1956 revolution yeah they had
a border wall
it was to keep people in america needs a
border wall to keep people out
because too many people black brown all
races from all over the world want to
come here
does that sound like a place to be
ashamed of of course not
it's something to be incredibly proud of
the fact that this country
is the number one choice for anyone
seeking
opportunity and when people do come here
in the legal way
it's the only place in the world that
truly fully
welcomes everyone into the national
family on
equal terms you can move to britain
but they'll never consider you british
not really
try becoming a french citizen see if
they'll let you call yourself french
or china forget about it who wants to
move to china anyway
there's a reason they don't have a
border crisis and it's not a good one
but here anyone can become an american
i just did because being american isn't
just about the physical space we inhabit
but the ideas
we represent the ideas that america was
built on the ideas
that every american old or new should
proudly support
the ideas expressed in our magnificent
founding documents the ideas we
celebrate today
so as a new citizen i'm not here to try
and turn america
into the place i left but to help
preserve and protect and defend what
makes
america special there's a reason this
country is so successful
there's a reason our enemies fear us and
our allies want to be us
because they know the power of the
constitution
which guarantees freedoms and rights
that are the basis of everything america
has achieved
right at the heart of it the principle
of decentralized
power checks and balances separation of
powers federalism limits
on the concentration of power that's why
i've argued we should pay more attention
to the tenth amendment the powers not
delegated to the united states by the
constitution nor prohibited by
to the states are reserved to the states
respectively or to their people
power to the people that's what creates
the american spirit
to pursue the american dream taking
risks chasing success
that's rewarded here not punished or
looked down upon
you don't see it so much in england you
didn't see it at all in the far left
system my parents escaped from in
communist hungary
but today the constitution the american
spirit
and the american idea is under attack
under attack from the concentration of
power in the hands of big tech
our power to say what we think what we
can read and see and hear
censoring information that challenges
the establishment narrative the
technocrats groupthink
the tech titans preferred politicians
whose pockets they've stuffed with cash
to do their bidding
the american idea is under attack from
big government
i'm not sure people have woken up to the
sheer scale
of what is being planned in washington
right now they really
are plotting to turn america into a
european style
welfare state most of the population
dependent on the government
massive taxes to pay for it an
unprecedented expansion of the federal
bureaucracy
emboldened by the pandemic power grabs
of the lockdown lunatics
they're exploiting the crisis they
created to unleash an
army of interferers and busy bodies and
managers
centralizing power over all our lives
in a way that's not just unacceptable
but unconstitutional
home health care child care parental
leave community college we can argue
about whether government should be
providing these things
but there's no question that the federal
government shouldn't the constitution is
clear
these are matters for the states and for
the people
our american idea is under attack from
china too
pulling the strings of hollywood
corporate america and the establishment
media
to subvert american interests and grow
their power
the wretched ceo of nike john donahoe
gave the game away
we are a brand that is of china and for
china
don't these useful idiots understand
don't they bother to read what chinese
leaders say
xi jinping and his rotten corrupt crew
have told us very clearly
their goal is to topple america as the
world's superpower by 2049
the 100th anniversary of the people's
republic a world run on the values of
this
evil authoritarian regime is a nightmare
look what they're doing already genocide
torture an orwellian tech enabled
system of social control all of it now
being exported
through their neo-colonialist
international adventurism we have to
fight
back and it starts with a total
decoupling of our economies we must
strike at the foundation
of china's rise the advantages we gave
them
by sending so much of our economy there
and of course the american idea is under
attack from
wokism the hateful intolerant ideology
that has captured the most powerful
institutions in america from the
boardroom to the oval office
the culmination of a 100 year war
on faith family and culture hijacking
our language
turning americans against each other
pushing hate and division and
intolerance and racism
in any case as i pointed out many times
on this show the main driver of racial
injustice in america today
is not racist white people from the 18th
century but race obsessed
democrats pushing policies that hurt
black and latino americans the most
and it's conservative ideas like strong
families and school choice
that offer the best prospect of
achieving what we all want to see
equal opportunity for every american
regardless of race
so on this july the 4th as we emerge
from a year that tested our limits
remember who we are as americans and
what we stand for
this country's future is bright as long
as we get off our knees and defend it
from those seeking to destroy it so
break up big tech
decentralize big government take on
china and defeat
wokism that's the next revolution we
need
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else